hey guys this is Eric and I'm back my
dog is barking I don't know if the mic
is picking that up I just wanted to make
a quick video about I really don't know
if people can hear that I want to make a
quick video about this made in one
trainer which has been making the rounds
on social media there's a whole reddit
post about it and it's a site which I
found to be a bit addictive it's it's
pretty fun like once you get into it
once you get the the rhythm of things so
what I'm gonna do is try to solve as
many mates in one as possible
I'll have 10 seconds per problem and
I'll try and get longest streak as
possible if I run out of time or if I
move an incorrect move then I'll end the
streak and and that will be that so my
personal record right now is a hundred
twenty problems in a row so I'm gonna
try and beat that and without further
ado let's get going let's click click
here to play again okay okay
there probably won't be too much
commentary cuz ten seconds is not a lot
of time where's the meat I'm I was so
clueless here isn't oh it's 95 because
each of seven is covered by the rook
I saw 95 and I thought King h7 didn't
see the rook okay that was terrible
let's do this again okay that was Queen
h6 okay he did worse in the previous
time okay one more time
mmm
Queen before
ah really have to double-check things
it wasn't Pontiac g5 I was Knight d4 I
got kind in a row okay we're gonna do
this one more time as long as I keep
improving I'll keep doing it I saw Queen
g8 as soon as I let go ah as before one
more time what wait what no oh that
wasn't even the right move because
ninety five but it didn't even like
registered the move that was weird that
was a complete fail zero okay I want to
at least break like a hundred let's do
this one more time focus stay calm
deep breath
stinky
Oh No I felt like I was on good rhythm
to it was e 6 e 6 is nice it opens up
the Queen and discover Czech meets the
king okay well I'm gonna end it there
the point of this was just to show the
YouTube audience who may have not seen
this before I'll leave links in the
description to the different types of
training exercises you can do with its
websites and and let me know what you
guys score can you beat
can you beat 42 can you beat five it's
not that easy especially doing it over
and over and over again so let me know
and good luck and have fun
see you guys